good afternoon
i want to speak today
to the unfolding situation in
afghanistan
the developments that have taken place
in the last week
and the steps we're taking to address
the rapidly evolving events
my national security team and i have
been closely monitoring the situation on
the ground in afghanistan
and moving quickly to execute the plans
we had put in place
to respond to every constituency
including and contingency
including the rapid collapse we're
seeing now
i'll speak more in a moment about the
specific steps we're taking
but i want to remind everyone how we got
here
and what america's interests are in
afghanistan
we went to afghanistan almost 20 years
ago with clear goals
get those who attacked us on september
11 2001
and
make sure al qaeda could not use
afghanistan as a base from which to
attack us again
we did that
we severely degraded al qaeda in
afghanistan
we never gave up the hunt for osama bin
laden and we got him
that was a decade ago
our mission in afghanistan was never
supposed to have been nation-building
it was never supposed to be creating a
unified centralized democracy
our only vital national interest in
afghanistan remains today what has
always been
preventing a terrorist attack on
america's homeland
i've argued for many years that our
mission should be narrowly focused on
counter-terrorism not
counter-insurgency or nation-building
that's why i opposed the surge
when it was proposed in 2009 when i was
vice president
and that's why as president i'm adamant
we focus on the threats we face today in
2021 not yesterday's threats
today
the terrorist threat has metastasized
well beyond afghanistan
al-shabaab in somalia
al-qaeda in the arabian peninsula
al-nusra in syria
isis attempting to create a caliphate in
syria and iraq
and establishing affiliates in multiple
countries
in africa and asia
these threats
warrant our attention
and our resources
we conduct effective counterterrorism
missions against terrorist groups and
multiple countries
where we don't have permanent military
presence
if necessary
we'll do the same in afghanistan
we've developed counterterrorism over
the horizon capability
that will allow us to keep our eyes
firmly fixed on the direct threats to
the united states in the region
and that quickly and decisively if
needed
when i came into office
i inherited a deal that president trump
negotiated with the taliban
under his agreement
u.s forces would be out of afghanistan
by may 1
2021
just a little over three months after i
took office
u.s forces had already
drawn down during the trump
administration from roughly 15
500 american forces
to 2 500 troops in country
and the taliban was at its strongest
militarily since 2001.
the choice i had to make as your
president
was either to follow through on that
agreement
or be prepared to go back to fighting
the taliban
in the middle of the spring fighting
season
there would have been no ceasefire after
may one
there was no agreement protecting our
forces after may one
there was no status quo of stability
without american casualties after may
one
there was only
a whole reality
of either following through on the
agreement
to withdraw our forces or escalating the
conflict
and sending thousands more american
troops back into combat in afghanistan
lurching
into the third decade of conflict
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we planned for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
so what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement in afghanistan now
was the right decision
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
we spent over a trillion dollars
we trained and equipped an afghan
military force
with some 300 000 strong
incredibly well-equipped
a force larger in size than the
militaries of many of our nato allies
we gave them every tool they could need
we paid their salaries
provided for the maintenance of their
air force
something that taliban doesn't have
taliban does not have an air force
we provided close air support
we gave them every chance
to determine their own future
we could not provide them
was the will to fight for that future
there's some very brave and capable
afghan special forces units and soldiers
but if afghanistan is unable to mount
any real resistance of the taliban now
there is no chance
that one year
one more year
five more years or 20 more years
u.s military boots on the ground would
have made any difference
here's what i believe
to my core
it is wrong to order american troops
to step up when afghanistan's own
armed forces would not
the political leaders of afghanistan
were unable to come together for the
good of their people unable to negotiate
for the future of their country when the
chips were down
they would never have done so while u.s
troops remained in afghanistan bearing
the brunt of the fighting for them
and our true strategic competitors
china and russia
would love nothing more than the united
states to continue to funnel billions of
dollars in resources and attention and
destabilized in afghanistan indefinitely
when i hosted president ghani and
chairman abdullah at the white house in
june
and again when i spoke by phone to gani
in july
we had very frank conversations
we talked about how afghanistan should
prepare to fight their civil wars
after the u.s military departed
to clean up the corruption in government
so the government could function
for the afghan people
we talked extensively about the need for
afghan leaders to unite politically
they fail to do any of that
i also urge them to engage in diplomacy
to seek a political settlement with the
taliban
this advice was flatly refused
mr ghani
insisted the afghan forces would fight
but obviously he was wrong
so i'm
left again to ask of those who argue
that we should stay
how many more generations of america's
daughters and sons
would you have me send to fight afghan
afghanistan's civil war
when afghan troops will not
how many more lives american lives is it
worth
how many endless rows of headstones is
arlington national cemetery
i'm clear of my answer
i will not repeat the mistakes we've
made in the past
mistake of staying and fighting
indefinitely
in a conflict that is not in the
national interest of the united states
of doubling down
on a civil war in a foreign country
of attempting to remake a country
through the endless military deployments
of u.s forces
those are the mistakes we cannot
continue to repeat
because we have significant vital
interest in the world
that we cannot afford to ignore
i also want to acknowledge how painful
this is to so many of us
the scenes were seen in afghanistan
they're gut-wrenching
particularly for our veterans
our diplomats humanitarian workers for
anyone who has spent time
on the ground working to support the
afghan people
for those who have lost loved ones in
afghanistan
and for americans have fought and served
in the country
serve our country in afghanistan
this is deeply deeply personal
it is for me as well
i've worked on these issues as long as
anyone
i've been throughout afghanistan during
this war while the war was going on from
kabul to kandahar
to the kunar valley
i've traveled there on four different
occasions
i met with the people
i spoken to the leaders
i spent time with our troops
and i came to understand firsthand
what was
and was not possible in afghanistan
so now we're
focused on what is possible
we will continue to support the afghan
people
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid we'll continue to push
for regional diplomacy and engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
just as we speak out all over the world
i've been clear
the human rights must be the center of
our foreign policy
not the periphery
but the way to do it is not through
endless military deployments
it's with our diplomacy our economic
tools
and rallying the world to join us
let me lay out the current mission in
afghanistan
i was asked to authorize and i did six
thousand u.s troops to deploy to
afghanistan
for the purpose of assisting in the
departure of u.s and allied civilian
personnel from afghanistan
and to evacuate our afghan allies and
vulnerable afghans to safety outside of
afghanistan
our troops are working to secure the
airfield
and ensure continued operation
of both the civilian and military
flights
we're taking over air traffic control
we have safely shut down our embassy
and transferred our diplomats
our diplomatic presence
is now consolidated at the airport as
well
over the coming days we intend to
transport out thousands of american
citizens
who've been living and working in
afghanistan
we'll also continue to support
the safe departure of civilian personnel
the civilian person all of our allies
who are still serving in afghanistan
operation allies refugee
which i announced back in july
has already moved 2 000 afghans who are
eligible for special immigration visas
and their families to the united states
in the coming days
the us military will provide assistance
to move to move more siv eligible
afghans and their families out of
afghanistan
we're also expanding refugee access to
cover other vulnerable afghans who
worked for our embassy
u.s non-government agencies or
u.s non-governmental organizations
and afghans
who otherwise are at great risk in u.s
news agencies
i know there are concerns about why we
did not begin evacuating
afghans civilians sooner
part of the answer
is some of the afghans did not want to
leave earlier still hopeful
for their country
and part of it because the afghan
government
and its supporters discouraged us from
organizing the mass exodus to avoid
triggering as they said
a crisis of confidence
american troops are performing this
mission
as professionally and as effectively as
they always do
but it is not without risks
as we carry out this departure
we have made it clear to the taliban
if they attack our personnel
or disrupt our operation
the u.s presence will be swift and the
response will be swift and
forceful
we would defend our people with
devastating force if necessary
our current military mission
we shorten time
limited
scope and focused in its objectives
get our people and our allies safely as
quickly as possible
and once we have completed this mission
we will conclude our military withdrawal
will end america's longest war
after 20 long years of bloodshed
the events we're seeing now
are sadly proof
that no amount of military force would
ever deliver a stable united secure
afghanistan
as known in history as the graveyard of
empires
what's happening now
could just as easily happen five years
ago
or 15 years in the future
we have to be honest
our mission in afghanistan has taken
many missteps made many missteps over
the past two decades
i'm now the fourth american president
to preside over war in afghanistan two
democrats and two republicans
i will not pass this responsibly on
responsibility onto a fifth president
i will not mislead the american people
by claiming that just a little more time
in afghanistan will make all the
difference
nor will i shrink from my share of
responsibility for where we are today
and how we must move forward from
here i am president of the united states
of america
and the buck stops with me
i'm deeply saddened by the facts we now
face
but i do not regret my decision to end
america's warfighting in afghanistan and
maintain
a laser focus on our counter-terrorism
missions there in other parts of the
world
our mission to degrade
the terrorist threat of al qaeda in
afghanistan and kill osama bin laden was
a success
a decades-long effort to overcome
centuries of history and permanently
change and remake afghanistan was not
and i wrote and believed it never could
be
i cannot and will not ask our troops to
fight on endlessly
another in another country's civil war
taking casualties
suffering life-shattering injuries
leaving families broken by grief and
loss
this is not in our national security
interest
it is not what the american people want
it is not
what our troops who have sacrificed so
much over the past two decades deserve
i made a commitment to the american
people
when i ran for president that i would
bring america's military involvement in
afghanistan to an end
while it's been hard and messy
and yes far from perfect
i've honored that commitment
more importantly
i made a commitment to the brave men and
women who served this nation
that i wasn't going to ask them to
continue to risk their lives in a
military action that should have ended
long ago
our leaders did that in vietnam when i
got here as a young man
i will not do it in afghanistan
i know my decision will be criticized
but i would rather take all that
criticism
than pass this decision on to another
president of the united states yet
another one a fifth one
because it's the right one it's the
right decision for our people
the right one for our brave service
members to risk their lives serving our
nation
that's the right one for america
thank you
may god protect our troops our diplomats
and all brave americans serving in
harm's way
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president what do you make of the
afghan swinging